[Música]
[Aplausos]
ora muito à noite a primeiro lugar dizer
que é um grande prazer estar aqui é um
grande prazer porque se calhar um pouco
mais de 40 anos ela em uma casa ao pé da
porta do sol quando eu vim alô a rua
quando na minha avó que eu apontava para
a rua e perguntava o que era aquela bola
que estava no céu e essa pergunta na
verdade nunca me saiu da cabeça eu eu
sempre fiquei muito curioso quando era
criança é sobre o que eram os astros que
vemos no céu à noite
esse bichinho de tentar perceber o que é
que o que nós vemos então no céu que
exista a nossa volta é foi crescendo e e
aos poucos eu fui começando a decrescer
astrônomo também que se por um lado fico
obviamente que não pára em uma criança é
no interior de portugal que na altura
entrou porque ela era muito mais longe
de lisboa e do porto do que é hoje
muita gente dizia lá tem que pagar nasa
ou enfim mais vale fazer outra coisa
mais terrena porque se calhar enfim vai
ser muito difícil ser essas coisas dos
anos o náutico mas foi extinto enfim sou
sou cachorro em atender a e e foi
conseguindo este sonho
obviamente com ajuda uma grande ajuda da
família e dos amigos
fui continuando a alimentar a ideia de
que podia ser astronauta aqui em
portugal é e aos poucos enfim a minha
pergunta é naturalmente deixou de ser o
que é lua e começou a ser mas uma
pergunta não querem mais profunda
à medida que fui fazendo os meus estudos
na faculdade e queria saber se estava no
solo universal não ou seja quando
olhamos para o céu fraca a outras terras
que nós não estamos a ver outros
planetas parecidos mais ou menos
parecido com a nossa terra e que nos
possam indicar se calhar nós não estamos
sozinhos no universo que há outros
sítios por esse universo fora onde a
vida possa ter desenvolvido e enfim
difícil fiz meus filhos meu doutoramento
justamente é tentar responder esta
pergunta
é mas talvez ainda nunca ninguém para
trás nós queremos tentar perceber a será
que existem ou não o colé será que é
provável que existam outras terras por
esse universo foram não é esse olhar mos
por nosso próprio sistema solar nós
aprendemos na escola o sistema solar tem
o sol e tem oito planetas à sua volta
tem oito planetas
quatro dos quais são feitos de rocha
pedras são duros quisermos como a nossa
terra sobre mercúrio vênus terra e marte
e pois tem quatro outros planetas que
são gigantes maioritariamente gigantes
gasosos são joão peter saturno urano e
neptuno são bastante maior do que o dos
planetas terrestres júpiter por exemplo
só para terem uma ideia tem cerca de 300
vezes mais massa do que a nossa terra e
dentro de seu caminhão mais de mil terra
nós conseguimos por mais de mil terras
dentro daquela bola ela e queijo bem mas
é isso é o que nós temos no nosso
sistema solar e como diz o próprio nome
sistema solar quer dizer que andam à
volta do sol e o solo é uma estrela
então quando nós vamos à noite e olhamos
para o céu se tivermos sobretudo um
sítio escuro nós vimos milhares de
estrelas só olho nu nós conseguimos ver
cerca de seis mil estrelas no céu mas
não só de fazer muito grandes
se tivéssemos os olhos muito mais
sensíveis à luz nós conseguimos ver
muito mais estrelas só para terem uma
ideia é apenas na nossa galáxia existem
cerca de 100 mil milhões de estrelas são
mais do que dez estrelas por cada pessoa
que existe na terra e portanto nós
podemos começar nos a perguntar o que
fazer
há tanta estrela por esse universo fora
será que nenhuma outra tem também o seu
cortejo do planeta da volta será que
será que os conseguimos até encontrar é
e foi de facto difícil mas em 1995 foi
um é muito muito importante nesta nesta
em toda esta procura em toda esta busca
porque foi em 1995 que uma equipe que
conseguiu finalmente provar que pelo
menos uma outra estrela no nós vemos um
céu nublado mas ela é razoavelmente
presidente que se vêem no céu noturno
tinha um planeta volta não era um
planeta qualquer não era um planeta
terra é um planeta é bastante estranho
porque era um planeta do tamanho de
júpiter o planeta gigantesco mas que
estava muito portinho da sua estrela tão
curtinho que a temperatura deste planeta
é de mais 1.000 graus
entretanto foram descobertos outros por
exemplo ainda relativamente pouco tempo
descobriu se um parecido com este que
que enfim chamaram os júpiteres quentes
do planeta parecido com o jogo dele está
muito perto da sua estrela
descobriu se um destes que é tão quente
que na sua atmosfera tem ferro evaporar
tanto imagine a temperatura do que
estamos a falar agora mas sua história
não são pacientes e são resistentes e
continuaram a lutar para encontrar mais
e mais e hoje já descobriram mais de
três mil planetas orbitando outras
estrelas e planetas muitos tipos
diferentes
alguns são como júpiter de planetas são
foi desgaste por tudo mas alguns lugares
a maioria são planetas foi de rocha
rocha como a nossa terra
não sabemos muito sobre elas ainda temos
algumas coisas que vemos que são o seu
tamanho sabemos para alguns casos qual é
a sua massa qual é mais ou menos a sua
composição química mas ainda não há
muito que se consiga saber sobre estes
planetas mas é uma coisa que nós já
sabemos é que a maioria das estrelas que
nós vemos no céu têm planetas à sua
volta e portanto é aquela primeira
pergunta que eu colocar aí será que
estamos sob um universo consultar alguma
forma é ter uma resposta
nós já sabemos que quando olhamos para o
céu é aquelas linhas que nós vemos a
maioria delas têm planetas que andam à
sua volta
não estou aqui falar planetas tenham
vida que tem 11 anos não estamos a falar
disso nós não sabemos ainda mas sabemos
que estão lá
o próximo passo é tentar descobrir
exatamente como é que o chão e alguns
casos são são muito interessante por
exemplo aqui mostra que há um ano e mais
em artista que nós não conseguimos tirar
fotografias como esta vai ser um planeta
é que na volta de uma estrela chama ela
idéias uns 40 é excepto os astrônomos
gostam por nomes complicados as coisas
só para confecção de 200 mas bom
ambiente é mas é essa não tem este nome
esquisito mas tem um planeta
os planetas à sua volta é um deus é um
projeto e também os shows como a nossa
terra é e que tem mais ou menos a
temperatura que nós paramos um planeta
que possa ter água foi uma das primeira
descoberta de planetas deste ano
não sabemos como é que eu é que não
sabemos tem água não tem mas pode ser
que tenha o importante aqui é uma das
coisas importantes aqui é que este
planeta foi descoberto também com
auxílio da equipe portuguesa
ou seja não é preciso que a nasa como a
bons anos atrás e ouvia é que em
portugal nós podemos participar nesta
conquista
e é verdade é que nós não sei se vocês
estão mais ou menos atento a jornais mas
de vez em quando as descobertas são
anunciadas também nos jornais na
televisão em que é tanto gueses
participam na descoberta de outros
mundos
isso é muito importante porque é uma
mensagem muito importante pra mim
transmitir seja mensagem de que em
portugal se possa fazer ciência ao mais
alto nível que somos capazes de estar na
crista da onda da ciência mundial e que
em portugal também se anda à procura
ativamente de encontrar outros mundos
por esse universo
no entanto todos os jovens que sejam ou
virtudes quiserem sonhar em ser os
tronos podem certamente selo astrônomos
em portugal bem e como eu disse nós
estamos à procura cada vez do planeta
cada vez mais de plantas mas mais
parecidas com a nossa terra é mas já
descobrimos como eu disse muita coisa
mas nós queremos descobrir mais e
queremos descobrir mais e isso implica o
desenvolvimento de novas tecnologias
é importante também aí percebi que
portugal está fazendo um grande um
grande esforço e está tendo um papel
importante por exemplo é muito
recentemente ficou pronto tá na verdade
neste momento temos colegas - lanuf ou
no observatório de toques finais mas
ficou pronto um aparelho nós chamamos um
instrumento no instrumento enfim não
interessa muito estádios é que vai
permitir encontrar planetas parecidos
com a terra a orbitar outras estrelas
parecidas com o nosso só talvez pela
primeira vez nós vamos ser capazes de
encontrar esse aparelho chama se
expresso
tem um nome que nos diz muito aos
portugueses gostam muito café mas mostra
no fundo como portugal tá nesta
conquista
este aparelho está instalado num
conjunto de quatro telescópios que
existem no rio são propriedade do
chamado observatório europeu do sul é um
consórcio internacional do qual portugal
faz parte e que explora os maiores
telescópios que existem no mundo e
tantos portugueses têm excesso estes
copos e podem fazer a melhor ciência com
os ventos parecem apenas um exemplo vai
começar agora eu espero que vocês
estejam muito atentos porque talvez nos
próximos meses já descobertas
não vou desvendar mais não estejam
atentos mas nós vamos olhar mais para
frente também a e também já a preparar
por exemplo uma participação naquilo que
vai ser o maior telescópio do mundo
daqui dez anos
é um outro telescópio está neste momento
a ser construído chama e distribuí-las
telas que eu ou em português dos copos
extremamente grande enfim eu não pouco
manter seu nome era é e nós temos também
a construir é para eles com esses
telescópios que nos vão permitir não
apenas de tentar descobrir se planetas
mas toda a sua atmosfera estudar a
atmosfera e tentar perceber se na
atmosfera desses planetas longínquos que
nós que nós vemos se existem ou não os
traços da assinatura de existência de
elementos que nos possam indicar que
existe vida ou não nesses planetas e
portanto é uma conquista que está a ser
feita em gradualmente passa paz como
toda a ciência que se faz lentamente mas
com muito empenho e que não está a
permitir caminhar nesse sentido de
encontrar outras terras
é muito importante também percebemos que
isso é feito não é projeto é feito por
astrônomos nos treinos são pessoas
pessoas como todos nós como todos vocês
aqui uma imagem apenas de uma parte da
equipe que nós temos no instituto só
física a que tem uma equipe muito
multicultural pessoas de vários países
desde a armênia
passando por vários países europeus o
irão
enfim temos cientistas de todo o mundo a
trabalhar em conjunto com a ciência não
tem fronteiras
estamos a tentar justamente encontrar
esses outros mundos universos e reparem
que a única coisa que move os cientistas
é é curiosidade e é voltado de descobrir
que não estamos sozinhos a vontade de
dar novo conhecimento a nossa humanidade
e portanto aos poucos eu acho que a
pergunta que eu colocar inicialmente
será que estamos nós só no universo
mudou e agora é pergunta já não é essa e
quando é que nós vamos encontrar uma
outra terra
um outro planeta azul ou vermelho ou
verde enfim vendas dos discos com vista
que cada uma é um planeta onde possa
existir realmente vida e onde onde
possamos finalmente responder essa
grande pergunta da humanidade
será que estamos ou não sozinhos no
universo
obrigado
[Aplausos]